uh first i got a series of questions by
someone named fantastic elevator six
um and you have to really watch me when
i say some of these usernames because if
it's a completely inappropriate
reference i'm not gonna get it so you
have to come in and say hey we
uh
we we don't support whatever eric just
said so
uh anyway
the series of questions was about my
recent transition to a vegetarian diet
and
i got a kick out of the the series of
questions uh they were they were
partially facetious but
um
i think that there's too much
attention
dedicated to the idea that a vegetarian
diet is like
wholly unsustainable and not compatible
with human life like like so um for
example like
uh
how is it incorporating all those beans
and legumes into the diet like it's fine
uh questions like you know
how has been like you know my gi system
dealing with all the additional plant
food uh
totally fine like no difference at all
question any change in supplementation
to uh to complement my dietary change
not really
i was already taking a multivitamin
and the only real change i made with
supplementation was instead of taking
fish oil i switched over to algae oil
which i actually much prefer greg we
were talking about this the other day
fish oil is known to have that kind of
fishy
smell to it sometimes and you know
sometimes you'll get the it's kind of
gross but the burps with the fishy
aftertaste that stuff grosses me out
with algae you feel like you're just
eating some delicious seaweed
it's really really nice so i actually
even if i were not a vegetarian i
would probably always go algae oil over
fish oil if given the chance
um
the uh and if like i said i'm not like
being dismissive of this series of
questions because they are good
questions um but yeah like people have
asked me is it hard to get protein in
honestly not really unless you're on a
really low calorie diet or your protein
is
realistically higher than you need you
know a lot of people are like dude i
can't do a vegetarian diet i could never
get the protein and it's like right but
why are you having like four grams per
kilogram of protein you know yeah um but
yeah so it really hasn't been that bad
there have been you know minor
inconveniences minor uh you know
situations where i have to think about
okay where am i going to get a
plant-based source of protein but
overall it's been a very easy change and
i haven't had to do anything too crazy
in terms of supplementation or anything
like that but the part of the question
that i thought was excellent uh
i would like an update on how the moral
superiority feels um is the
lack of cognitive dissonance making your
thinking clearer and his lack of b12
killing all your gains so a
excellent string of questions um
wait where were people actually asking
that yeah it was it was in it was it's a
facetious list of questions here oh
about going vegetarian um
one of the things that's funny is i did
run into like a major issue of cognitive
dis right
i ran into a moral conundrum so
my girlfriend's cat is
uh needed a switch in food and we're
trying to figure out uh they stopped
selling her old food and she's allergic
to a lot of the common foods and we're
trying to figure out what kind of food
to get from my girlfriend's cat
and uh
dude they made me sad like there was
like she was like should we get this
food made of rabbits and i'm like dude
no not not the little rabbits and then
like yeah we went through this whole
list of animals and finally settled on a
salmon-based food for the cat based on
which animal do we feel less sad about
about eating yeah um
because you know
the cat is a lovely cat but uh
unfortunately an obligate carnivore
so
the cat will be eating meat and so yeah
we still buy these food products made of
animals but fortunately we were able to
avoid uh the bunny food that was that
was a little bit over the line for me
but uh anyway yeah so
it's been good and it's not not that bad